very buff in these puzzles you have to
move random unattended items back and
forth across a river for instance you
might need to get a chicken eating wolf
a cabbage eating chicken in an
understandably inert cabbage across the
river on a ferry boat that holds only
two items at a time this raises
questions first off what delivery
service allows you to send unrestrained
wildlife secondly if someone handed you
a single chicken and said that it was
really important for that chicken to get
somewhere wouldn't you suspect
drug-running
and finally what sort of ferry can hold
a wolf and a chicken so precisely that
there's absolutely no room left over for
a single head of cabbage couldn't you
just strap it to the wolf c-plus
arithmetic filling this gives you a
simple addition or subtraction problem
with some blank spaces that you have to
fill in with the numbers one through
nine to get an answer that's as correct
as it is boring if I wasn't excited the
time that I had to calculate the tip at
a hopper out while on fire then your
little blank space gambit isn't really
gonna get my blood racing d-plus age
puzzles I really enjoyed these but at
the same time it bugs me how people in
logic problems will never just tell you
they're freaking age it's always well if
you take half of Alfred's age and add
Betty's then you get the average of my
and Carl's age I'd like to see them try
that once they get carted into dive bar
how do you well if you take a third of
the age of that single malt scotch 26
times 26 I'll be misunderstood word
puzzles I really hate these they seem
like simple problems at first but they
rely on a perverse and intentional
misunderstanding of plain English so
some will say what's the last letter in
the alphabet T you see it's the last
letter in the word alphabet the worst
part of it is that it makes me doubt the
wording of legitimate logic puzzles so I
end up thinking myself ok I'm
calculating the distance to the moon but
wait a second am i calculating the
distance to the word
moon or maybe on calculating the word
distance to the word moon do you see
what this does to me
demons Sudoku the thing I appreciate
about Sudoku is it's just simple numbers
and lines I mean Sudoku doesn't actually
involve math so they could have used
anything they could made it some
tarted-up analogy where Farmer Brown has
nine fields on each field has nine
Corral's and in the Corral's he has to
put cows chickens wolves cabbages
rutabagas portable television sets
Trader Joe's frozen pad thai dinners
human cadavers and hope but they didn't
and that's why even though Sudoku is
taken over airport newspaper stands like
paper kudzu I still look kindly upon
that simple grid b-plus